welcome back cabinet unity has been an
elusive thing in recent times but it's
been achieved at least for now without a
single resignation but will it last
joining me to discuss the Conservative
Party Chairman Brandon Lewis mr. Lewis
very good morning to you good morning
how did you reason into it you know
whenever I take a trip away with my
mates for the weekend you know at least
a couple of his end up falling open
she's managed to get them all to agree
to things that they previously said they
would never agree to well I should I
think partly the reality is we all get
on very well and very focused on having
one key outcome which is a United
cabinet with a clear position for the
British government for the United
Kingdom to get a good deal because we
leave the European Union that's
something everybody was united on we had
good days discussions and we've come to
a completely agreed cabinet position you
were there I mean did Boris Johnson
describe it as a turd well I think one
of the challenges with a 13-hour day of
a lot of serious meetings is first of
all I've always taken a rule not to go
through and give details of what's been
said by individuals in cabinet and it's
very easy to take a what can sometimes
be seen as a joke in a particular
conversation somewhat out of context and
make story out of it the reality is boys
and all of us came to the agreement
about a strong package that we think
he's good for the United Kingdom economy
delivers on what the brexit vote was
about in 2016 assembly represents a very
strong leave constituency that's really
important to me as a Christian see MP as
well as a member of the cabinet and a
deal that's good for our economy as we
leave the European Union let's try and
work through a few of the bits and as if
everyone in this program has said today
we need to wait until we see the white
paper but you may know more than I do in
fact I'm sure you do know more than I do
in terms of the arrangement on good
times that exactly going to work well
the full details is you say quite a
while you'll be in that white paper
which will publish on Thursday this week
and what we're saying is on goods which
is that roughly comments for about 20%
of what we do we're saying up front we
would have that common wall booked and
that's quite a sensible thing if you're
doing any trade deal from scratch with a
big part let alone the single biggest
trading bloc in the world it's logical
you would have an agreement
upfront about how that works what those
goods are but importantly as we go
forward should you up after that point
decide to make changes the British
Parliament at the UK gun will have the
chance to say yes
no and there's a good example of this we
did this effectively actually just a few
weeks ago in Parliament considered the
new rules on GDP are with data and
things like that and took a decision to
go forward so we had good data access
and sharing across Europe as well so
Parliament will be solving on any
changes as we go forward we'll discuss
that the sovereignty point in just a
second but but it strikes me that given
ours is a services based economy I mean
the other 80% comes from that financial
services we're losing passports
I mean we're going to lose jobs as a
result of the deal that is currently on
the table proposed by to resuming in the
financial services sector well actually
this is the key part of the deal is that
we've got that flexibility around the
part of our economy our service is set
to financial services that not just
important in terms of the work we do in
the EU and we want to make sure we get a
good deal with the EU but actually is
where the growth and opportunities are
for us to trade globally and
internationally there are huge
opportunities for us whether it's with
America Asia and other parts of the
world we do those things we very well
may reshape our entire economy over a
period of years but in terms of losing
you EU passport that is going to have a
negative impact on financial services
here that is going to mean lost jobs
isn't it actually well I think what this
package can offer and we need to see
Europe get serious about coming forward
and discussing and negotiating these
opportunities that they're there because
we are such important trading parts on
services financial services as well we
are such a center for financial services
there is a really good opportunity
actually I think for growth and
investment and we're seeing that week in
week out as businesses continue to
invest in the UK but you can't guarantee
can you that there will not be jobs lost
in the financial services sector that
there will not be money lost to the UK
Exchequer as a result of you losing
Passport well actually what the wild
Contessa I use a slightly different
terminology which is I am absolutely
confident that this package will mean
our economy including financial services
can continue to grow in terms of the
work it does with our partners in
business Saints across Europe but also
with the rest of the world that's good
for the economy and can lead to more
jobs so isn't the truth of this this
common rubric and I understand why you
use that phraseology isn't the truth
that in essence in perpetuity we are
bound to the rules that the European
Union sets that those more brexit II
colleagues of yours who say that we will
be a real taker and not a rule maker
they are 100 percent correct
actually no I don't accept that at all I
think we've got to be very clear as with
any trade deal you would agree at the
beginning a rulebook around how that
will work I think it's right when we
make that decision to do that not least
of all because if you're selling goods
into the EU they would and if you sell
goods into Americana there's a rule and
there will clearly be consequences if as
you say we exert our sovereignty and we
see no more consequences would be a
massive hit to our national finance or
the key point I was gonna make now which
I've just finished is to say in if you
bu later on decides to make changes yes
we will have the right to say no we're
not so we're not gonna be a rule taker
we have the choice whether we do I mean
as with any trade I mean it's just it's
face-saving just let me finish
as with any trade deal if you have a
negotiated position and one party then
wants to change those rules down the
line the other party has a chance to say
no you do that give the sovereign choice
fella but you have to yes think about
what that means does it mean good
opportunities does it mean that there is
a consequence and absolutely but we can
make that decision and that'll be a
matter for the British UK government and
Parliament can you explain the position
on the ECG and and the idea that it will
no longer haven't utility here yes
absolutely what it means at the moment
an individual and organization or
business at a court can go directly to
the ECG s effectively our country's
Supreme Court that will end under this
package that absolutely ends so that the
the laws are decided by British courts
now one of the points that's been raised
I think I heard earlier on on this show
and certainly on a few things we'll seen
over the last 24 hours is that in effect
British courts would take account of
what the ECJ does yeah the reality is
British courts take a callable
canadian-american Australia's court
stars where they're relevant to UK law
but difficulty anywhere else now you're
taking a decision in the Canadian
Supreme Court wouldn't it it would be as
interpreting our laws in line with
European laws where we have an agreement
to do so isn't mass errect it's not the
same as Canada it's not the cities no
actually it's not quite like that either
what happens at the moment is people can
go directly to that cause the Supreme
Court that in so the EC JS directorís
diction ends exactly what people want to
when they voted in the referendum if
there is a dispute that goes beyond that
there will be a
mechanism which we will outline in that
white paper that's a joint committee
that would come together as it does in
any international trade deal but that
direct reference the ECJ would end yeah
but in six circumstances particularly
queer it applies to goods we would have
in essence High Court Court of Appeal
Supreme Court ECG still no no the
Supreme Court the UK Supreme Court would
be our top court would make the
decisions they can and it's a matter for
the court taking all the decisions of
the East Asian care they can take
account of ecj decisions in terms of how
you interpret European law and European
goods in the same way they would on
Canadian on Canadian because if we had a
trade deal in that sense with Canada
that's that's common practice but the e
C J's direct jurisdiction would end in
what sense is this this Agreement ending
freedom of movement oh absolutely it's
one of the things that Prime Minister's
been sexually clear about consistently I
think in our time as Home Secretary as
well as had one of those toughest
stances that we have seen him short in
sense of making sure we did it on
something but I know my residents and
many around the country feel strongly
about that is that freedom of movement
will end next year when we leave the
European Union what this paper that's
the three pages we put out and white
paper will give more detail on Thursday
outlines is about making sure that a bit
the GEMA businessman visiting the UK to
go and see their car manufacturing plant
without naming a particular car plant
can come and do that easy a British
businessman going to do a deal in France
call holidaymakers going to Spain this
summer can do that as easily as they do
now this is not about this is not about
people coming here to live in my
immigration sense that policy our
immigration policy from whence we've
left the European Union as we've said
before we will publish now after the
independent migration Advisory Committee
has fed back to the government in
September this year
the Home Secretary Sajid Javid is very
keen to have a modern new immigration
system that delivers for this country
and that's a separation but it strikes
me that this mobility framework you know
the EU and UK citizens can continue to
travel to each other's territories and
apply for a study and work I mean that's
what goes on right now well actually one
of the things we want to do is to make
sure that those systems can continue to
do business I want to be able to go and
see my counterparts around Europe as
easily as I do now I want British
businessman we have to go out there do
those deals and bring that business back
some because there will be a cap then on
in migration there will be an end to
freedom of movement what Luiza
the only reason I'm not going to outline
a guarantee cap is because got the
migration Advisory Committee I as
immigration minister in my last job in
the Home Secretary and the Prime
Minister have all been clear we want to
take an evidence-based approach to our
new immigration policy and we'll do that
ask the migration Advisory Committee has
fed back but freedom of movement that
freedom to come and live here and work
here from the EU o for 12 months or more
which is immigration that ends when we
leave the European in the absence of a
commitment to a cap on migration on
immigration from the European Union this
looks very much like that freedom of
movement has welcomed the sense in the
sense if you're interpreting the kappa's
freedom of movement
absolutely freedom of movement from the
European Union ends where we leave in
March 2019 just going back to that
meeting at Chequers when were you
surprised that people like David Davis
who described this situation that
there's this document in very negative
terms Liam Fox Boris Johnson all very
easily fell into line I mean the
assertion made earlier in the program is
that this was rather more to do with the
Conservative Party holding itself
together rather than the good of the
nation actually what I saw on Friday and
what I see consistent with my colleagues
across the Camrys we got a great pool of
talent in the party generally and
certainly in the cabinet specifically it
was people coming together to come up
with a package and a deal that is
absolutely the right package and deal
for the United Kingdom on one that we
can negotiate and deliver with our
partners in Europe important friends and
training partners but also be good for
the United Kingdom and this is about the
government coming together to do the
right thing for the country as far as
Johnson's ministerial car matter more to
him than his principal boys he's
absolutely focused on getting the right
deal for the country as we all are and
that's what brings us together and means
we're such as strongly united cabinet
after that take that as I'm not an
answer but I'll take that anyway mr.
Lewis many thanks for being with us
always good to see you